día 7 de enero del 2020 primera hora de
la tarde en nueva york' salta la noticia
al menos dos docenas de misiles
balísticos contra posiciones
estadounidenses concretamente el
objetivo fueron dos bases militares
iraquíes en las que se encuentran
desplegados cientos de soldados del
ejército de los eeuu
i
claro que todo esto no es más que la
continuación de una escalada en la
tensión entre irán y eeuu que tuvo su
punto álgido el pasado 3 de enero de
2020 ese día el ejército de los eeuu
lanzó un fulminante ataque nocturno
sobre un convoy cuando éste abandonaba
el aeropuerto de la capital iraquí
dentro de ese convoy viajaban dos
personajes muy importantes en la
geopolítica de oriente medio por un lado
el poderoso comandante de la fuerza quds
del cuerpo de la guardia revolucionaria
islámica de irán qasem soleimani uno de
los pesos pesados del régimen teocrático
de irán y junto a él la bomba vial
mohand y jefe de la milicia iraquí
kataib & paul a una milicia fundada en
2003 para luchar contra las tropas
estadounidenses desplegadas en el país
[Música]
ahora bien quién era realmente qasem
soleimani que significa su pérdida
porque trump tomó la decisión de acabar
con su vida cómo y por qué y dan ha
lanzado misiles balísticos contra
posiciones norteamericanas y amigos la
pregunta más importante de todas que
puede ocurrir ahora estamos acaso a las
puertas de una guerra entre los eeuu e
irán
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
no hablamos de cualquier personaje sino
precisamente de uno de los grandes
protagonistas a ojos de occidente algo
así como editar vader el joker el hans
landa de la política internacional
[Música]
y amigos que hacen solo y manera el
líder militar más importante dirán y
quizás el segundo líder más poderoso de
todo el país tan solo por detrás del
propio líder supremo alí jamenéi
[Música]
y como ya os hemos contado en visual
político irán es uno de los
archienemigos de los eeuu así que blanco
y en botella
pero para entender realmente quién era
solo imán tenemos que comprender cómo
funciona la peculiar estructura militar
de este país irán no tiene un ejército
sino que la práctica tiene dos ejércitos
que funcionan de forma independiente si
si dos ejércitos fijados
[Música]
por un lado está el ejército común un
ejército que cuenta con algo más de
350.000 soldados y que según el artículo
143 de la constitución iraní es el
responsable de las funciones típicas la
protección del territorio el control de
las fronteras la seguridad de las
infraestructuras esenciales etcétera
etc
y por otro lado está la guardia
revolucionaria que es un cuerpo
independiente que se creó en 1979 tras
la revolución islámica de jomeiní
precisamente para defender la revolución
defenderla entre otras cosas de un
posible golpe de estado del propio
ejército
[Música]
vamos que además de las pulgas
habituales como los ayatolás seguían sin
fiarse de nadie pues se montaron su
propio ejército no sé a qué les pasará
lo mismo persa
desde entonces su peso no ha parado de
crecer y crecer hoy es todo un ejército
con unos 150.000 efectivos y están mucho
mejor equipados mejor entrenados y mejor
financiados que el ejército iraní de
hecho esta guardia no responde ante el
gobierno sino directamente ante el líder
supremo es decir ante la autoridad
religiosa pues bien dentro de esta
guardia revolucionaria encontramos una
división autónoma la fuerza quds que es
algo así como una mezcla entre lo que
sería la cia y los cuerpos especiales es
decir un cuerpo de élite e inteligencia
que se encarga de todas las operaciones
en el extranjero hablamos de la punta de
lanza la joya de la corona de la
república islámica de irán el órgano
responsable de extender los tentáculos
de irán más allá de sus fronteras
y es amigos ese es precisamente el
cuerpo que desde hace 22 años dirigía su
alemán y lo que le había convertido por
así decirlo en el cerebro el arquitecto
del creciente peso de irán a lo largo y
ancho de todo oriente medio
de hecho con el paso de los años este
personaje se convirtió de facto en el
responsable de toda la política regional
de lo que junto a su control sobre las
redes de inteligencia y su cercanía el
líder supremo hicieron que en la
práctica solimani fuera más importante e
influyente que el propio presidente del
país
[Música]
sabéis cómo se refería a él el líder
supremo el ayatolá jamenéi pues ni más
ni menos que como un mártir viviente de
la revolución y es que lo cierto es que
este tipo supo hacer su trabajo
realmente bien tan solo tenemos que
echar un vistazo a cómo lo describen
algunos halcones en washington durante
dos décadas sulimani ha sido el
terrorista más poderoso inteligente y
efectivo del planeta ha disfrutado del
pleno respaldo del poderoso estado
terrorista insustituible marc dubois
director ejecutivo de la fundación para
la defensa de las democracias y es que
al frente de la fuerza quds alemany ha
tejido una red multinacional que durante
los últimos años se ha convertido en
todo un quebradero de cabeza para eeuu y
también para israel un momento no os lo
creéis pues fijaos
[Música]
tras la invasión norteamericana de irak
en el año 2003 la fuerza quds se dedicó
a organizar entrenar y armar a las
milicias que no le pusieron las cosas
nada pero que nada fáciles a los
norteamericanos irán incluso instruyó a
estas milicias en el uso de explosivos
sofisticados que logran perforar el
blindaje de los vehículos militares y
que han causado cientos de bajas entre
las tropas estadounidenses milicias que
por cierto hoy cuentan con decenas y
decenas de miles de efectivos y que
luchan por el control total de irak
[Música]
algo similar ha ocurrido en afganistán
donde esta organización iraní ha
suministrado armas explosivos equipos e
incluso apoyo directo a los talibanes
para enfrentarse a las tropas
internacionales comandadas por eeuu en
2006 el apoyo masivo a su plataforma
libanesa hezbollah hizo que por primera
vez el ejército de israel no ganara una
guerra y se tuviera que retirar tras una
invasión desastrosa
más tarde en síria el apoyo masivo al
régimen de al-assad ha sido clave para
evitar su caída y ahí no termina todo en
yemen las milicias pro iraníes han
conseguido hacer frente al poderoso
ejército saudí en gaza- la fuerza quds
juega un papel clave en el
aprovisionamiento y entrenamiento de
hamas e incluso han sido también
responsables de acciones como estas dos
importantes instalaciones petroleras
sauditas fueron golpeadas por un ataque
con aviones no tripulados y eeuu culpa
irán tiran se apodera de un petrolero
británico en el estrecho de ormuz en
otras palabras la pérdida de solimán y
ha sido un duro golpe para el régimen de
los ayatolás todo un misil en la línea
de flotación nunca mejor dicho
el drone de eeuu no solo se llevó por
delante a la figura clave de la política
exterior y militar del país sino que
también en cierto modo ha supuesto toda
una humillación para un país que en gran
medida basa su política exterior en dar
miedo porque vamos a ver eso de que se
lleven por delante con un dron al
responsable de tu servicio de
inteligencia y de tus cuerpos especiales
pues qué queréis que os diga no queda
muy bien no dice mucho del nivel de esos
grupos es imposible exagerar la
importancia de esta acción en particular
es más significativa que el asesinato de
osama bin laden o incluso la muerte del
líder del estado islámico abu bakr al
bagdadí general david petraeus es
comandante de las fuerzas
estadounidenses en irak y afganistán y
ex director de la cia pero amigos
llegados a este punto la pregunta
obligada la pregunta que nos tenemos que
hacer es por qué trans decidió llevar a
cabo ese ataque porque desencadenar
justo ahora semejante crisis política y
diplomática atentos
solamente las claves tras la decisión
del presidente atrás
seamos sinceros la animadversión y las
ganas de cargarse a este tío no son algo
precisamente nuevo en washington
prácticamente todas las administraciones
norteamericanas han tenido en el punto
de mira soleimani desde que asumió el
control de la fuerza quds sin embargo
hasta ahora nadie había querido tan
lejos y la pregunta es por qué trama ha
tomado ahora la decisión de llevárselo
por delante hace lo que algunos estáis
pensando si te conozco crees que vamos a
decir que ha sido todo por un impulso
una rabieta o una idea de olla del
presidente norteamericano verdad
[Música]
pues no lo siento pero si piensas así
has fallado hay al menos tres razones
que explican un ataque que ha puesto la
política internacional patas arriba
[Música]
veréis la primera razón tiene que ver
con la situación en irak que vive un
entorno explosivo desde hace meses el
enfrentamiento entre partidarios y
detractores de la influencia iraní en
irak se ha desatado hasta el punto de
que oirán ha puesto el pie en el
acelerador para tratar de tomar el
control de su vecino
de esta forma las milicias entrenadas
financiadas y dirigidas por irán no sólo
se han enfrentado y reprimido a las
fuerzas opositoras sino que también han
empezado otra vez a hostigar y atacar a
las propias tropas estadounidenses que
por supuesto apoyan a los sectores no
otorgaría y puede que te preguntes pero
para qué pues muy sencillo para
conseguir que los americanos se piden
del país eso es lo que explica por
ejemplo los ataques a las bases
norteamericanas que se han producido en
los últimos meses o también el intento
de asaltar la mismísima pasaba
miles de manifestantes atacan la
embajada de eeuu en bagdad al grito de
muerte a eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y lo cierto es que todo apuntaba a que
sólo iban y salía desplazado a esta
banda para organizar y coordinar ataques
masivos contra la presencia militar
norteamericana y preparar el asalto
definitivo a las instituciones iraquíes
work with jon stewart
[Música]
bien la segunda explicación tiene que
ver precisamente con el año en el que
estamos 2020 y que hay en 2020 exacto
elecciones
[Música]
y amigos que es más popular en los eeuu
que acabar con todo un enemigo declarado
en año electoral y oye si eso además
ayuda a desviar la atención del
impeachment o de la falta de resultados
en política exterior pues mejor que
mejor
por último el tercer motivo está
relacionado con esta falta de resultados
veréis desde que llegó a la casa blanca
ha mantenido una política de presión
creciente hacia irán para tratar de
lograr sus objetivos y que el régimen de
los ayatolás encara la rodilla y tenemos
la ruptura del acuerdo nuclear o las
sucesivas sanciones económicas que se le
han impuesto a irán
venidos pues bien como nada de eso ha
funcionado ahora ha tocado ir un poco
más allá al tiempo que este ataque
permite que eeuu recobre un activo muy
pero que muy importante en política
exterior el peso de la disuasión es
decir el miedo a las represalias
pero amigos tras un ataque de semejante
magnitud la pregunta que todos nos
hacemos es y ahora qué puede ocurrir
estaremos realmente a las puertas de una
guerra en oriente medio'
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la venganza
gran ha jurado venganza el golpe ha sido
tan duro que el régimen está en shock
los criminales que han manchado sus
manos con la sangre del general
soleimani y de otros mártires en el
ataque deben esperar una dura venganza
alí jamenéi líder supremo de irán sin
duda la gran nación de irán y otras
naciones libres de la región se vengarán
por este crimen del criminal eeuu hassan
rohan y presidente de irán
el lanzamiento de al menos dos docenas
de misiles balísticos contra las bases
iraquíes en erbil y al asad ha sido la
primera respuesta furiosa ahora bien
quiere decir esto que el régimen de los
ayatolás está dispuesto a lanzarse a
toda una guerra contra el imperio
americano
pues con riesgo de equivocarme me
atrevería a decir que no al menos no
tendría ningún sentido una cosa es
querer venganza y otra muy diferente es
cavar de tu propia tumba y es que no
sólo es una cuestión de capacidad
militar que evidentemente también lo es
sino que el fuerte de iran es jugar de
una forma muy pero que muy diferente que
irán va a vengar el ataque lo sabían
hasta en el reino de tonga dados los
precedentes lo podemos considerar
prácticamente como un hecho la pregunta
era y es básicamente como demonios lo
van a hacer
la república islámica de irán se niega a
tomar medidas emocionales y apresuradas
estableceremos un plan pacientemente
para responder a este acto terrorista de
una manera aplastante y poderosa somos
quien establecemos la hora y el lugar de
nuestra respuesta recíproca general a
bolt faz shekarchi portavoz de las
fuerzas armadas de irán y según parece
eso es exactamente lo que han hecho si
vale han disparado más de dos docenas de
misiles balísticos y han creado una
alarma enorme en todo el planeta pero
esperad un momento porque puede que no
todo sea exactamente tal y como parece
[Música]
en el momento de publicar este vídeo la
información que tenemos es que el ataque
se ha efectuado sobre dos instalaciones
secundarias para los eeuu y que no ha
causado bajas en las filas del ejército
norteamericano es decir la guardia
revolucionaria habría escogido dos
objetivos con los que darse golpes en el
pecho reivindicarse lanzar una enorme
campaña de marketing dentro de irán
sembrar el caos en el vecino irak que es
lo que quieren y al mismo tiempo reducir
el riesgo de una respuesta contundente
de los eeuu
algo así como tensar la situación para
destensar la
[Música]
aunque ojo porque esto no quiere decir
que aquí termine todo y no hablo de eeuu
sino de la república islámica de irán si
mis queridos amigos de visual política
este país tiene un enorme historial de
combatir sin hacer la guerra es decir
sin soldados uniformados sin tanques sin
aviones y declaraciones de traté trate
trabamos lo que viene siendo una guerra
de las de toda la vida pero no el fuerte
de irán no es nada de eso sino actúa
mediante lo que llamamos la guerra
asimétrica es decir organizando ataques
informales perpetrados por grupos
apoyados entrenados y financiados por
irán pero que estrictamente hablando no
son el gobierno digan
de hecho ese tipo de estrategias eran la
gran especialidad del señor soleimani es
algo que el régimen de los ayatolás ha
hecho desde siempre y como cuando por
ejemplo en el año 1983 hezbollah voló
por los aires un cuartel de los marines
de los estados unidos- en el líbano
causando más de doscientas bajas o como
cuando ayudó a hezbollah a volar la
embajada de israel en buenos aires y el
centro judío más importante de argentina
en el año 1992
[Música]
pero no hace falta irse tan lejos allí
están las milicias en irak atacando a
los soldados estadounidenses durante
años ataques que llevaron a cabo con
explosivos suministrados por iran y que
se calcula causaron más de 600 bajas por
no hablar de afganistán actos como los
que hemos visto en 2019 cuando irán de
forma directa o indirecta derribo un
drone estadounidense cuando hostigó y
retuvo petroleros en el estrecho de
ormuz o como cuando en septiembre atacó
las dos principales instalaciones
petroleras de arabia saudita así es cómo
juegan las fuerzas quds los propios
cohetes que hamas utiliza para atacar
israel tienen su sello y esa es
exactamente la respuesta que podemos
esperar es una gran amenaza el hecho de
que tengamos f-16 y f-35 no es relevante
para este problema general de brigada
jubilado yoshikawa ser jefe de la
división de investigación en la rama de
inteligencia militar de la fuerza de
defensa de israel las capacidades son
tan diferentes que otro escenario sería
prácticamente imposible incluso aunque
la guardia revolucionaria se haya
atrevido a lanzar los misiles balísticos
para que os hagáis una idea el tanque
más potente del ejército iraní es el t
72 ruso
en funcionamiento desde comienzos de los
años 70 también siguen utilizando
tanques que datan de la guerra de korea
o de la guerra de vietnam y la situación
de la fuerza aérea es aún peor
claro que todo podría cambiar con la
reacción de eeuu lo cierto es que una
ocupación de iran no parece nada
recomendable podría convertirse en una
auténtica pesadilla para los eeuu y es
que hablamos de un país enorme con
cientos de miles de soldados preparados
para la batalla uno de los mejores
sistemas de defensa antiaérea del
planeta y miles de misiles de corto y
medio alcance que aunque no podrían
atacar a eeuu si podrían hacerle mucho
daño a aliados como israel emiratos o
arabia saudita
así que es algo sorpresa mayúscula lo
que podemos esperar es mucha tensión y
mucha mucha guerra asimétrica en fin
amigos así están las cosas pero ahora
turno para ti crees que finalmente a
pesar de todo veremos una guerra entre
eeuu e irán déjanos tu respuesta en los
comentarios y ya sabes si este vídeo
resultó interesante
no olvides darle a like una vez más
muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]